a world of luxury right at your
fingertips sheer opulence Shia opulence
looking reliable I want I won't promote
you to General
I'm afraid I cannot accept that was my
dream when I got here
but my goals have changed
I have changed
I'm going to start my own business
a strip club for women
is this some kind of joke not at all I
mean do you like looking at naked dudes
I have something to tell you about women
get horny
I love this place you need me you need a
choreographer and I do enjoy a challenge
cuffs and collars you are a genius this
could be huge this could be Global
Russia China the whole world repeat
after me things are going incredibly
well things are going incredibly well
and I'm not gonna blow it I'm not going
to deploy
please welcome Mr Chippendales himself
Nick denoya Chippendales is my creation
I hired him you and me stick together or
we go to war is kind of threat it's a
promise he's gonna walk all over you
every cent I have I've put into this
club
oh yeah blood will spill
we have to call them
Mr Banerjee this is the FBI
I am the boss You're a murderer
I have everything I regret nothing I'm
going to burn this place to the ground
you're a bad man Mr venergy You Ain't
Seen Nothing Yet
[Music]